it's a crazy crazy world war in Chris
Hopkins with me Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author a couple
times over his latest is everyday
millionaires their every day millionaire
you're probably not laying awake at
night right unless it's about something
else that's right
breathing easy and clear why because you
had a game plan and you followed it
overtime and guess what on the way to
doing that you've weathered some storms
my friends you've seen some stuff
whether it was the SARS situation in o2
and o3 market job 12% but bio 3 came
back 19% the Great Recession of o70 9 18
months we saw right it became back so
we've grown up we've seen some stuff and
what we don't want to forget is that the
market is going to come back I don't
know when but I know for a fact that
it's going to yeah because the only
other alternative is to assume that the
entire economy completely implodes and I
just there's no historical point of
reference for that no and you know
that's a pretty heavy chicken little
statement if you say America is coming
to an end here and that's where you have
to get to to say all the businesses that
you drive by that you recognize their
names Apple McDonald's coca-cola
Microsoft Home Depot Lowe's the movie
theater AMC you know you who's that
you're driving a Ford Chevrolet General
Motors you know all these places you're
driving by or suddenly not just down in
value if you assume that your that your
mutual funds are worth zero you're
assuming all of those companies have a
zero value that's astronaut it is it
really is indeed to go back 30 days from
now and look at where the market was
antic glance now fast forward to where
we are and to say that that what was
happening in February was false is
unreal - yeah and so what we have to do
is wake up okay I know it's scary out
there but I'm gonna tell you something
be
clear and seeing this stuff for what it
is it allows you to properly respond
Dave I've been telling people on my
Instagram and Facebook lives there's
three things you can control and there's
actually four your attitude your outlook
and your actions but also your faith and
when you see and you see this for what
it is you don't want to waste energy on
anything that's not worthy mm-hmm it's
exactly right and all you can control
the controllables that's right that's
exactly darts with what's between your
ears yeah and you got to start with
controlling what's between yours
we would not allow our kids when they
were growing up to say he made me mad
mmm he make you anything you decided do
to the way he was misbehaving to be mad
that might be righteous anger it might
been an injustice but he didn't make you
happy he/she didn't make you mad the
coronavirus didn't make you afraid you
decided to be hmm and just as quickly as
you decide to be you can decide not to
be and now again we're not saying
positive thinking is you know Pollyanna
rustic your head in the sand at printing
like something's not going on if you're
facing some real stuff like our company
right now our guys I got a thousand
people working from home our
productivity is down revenues are gonna
go down following that we're facing some
stuff at rimsey solutions right now real
stuff and you know I sure hope we get
back to work soon yeah because if we
don't it's gonna be a problem and it's
gonna be a problem for a lot of people
out there
yeah and already a problem for a lot of
people out there so the you know you
you're clear-eyed but I'm also not gonna
over steer you over correct just because
I've got a some stress or because I've
got some concern I'm not gonna pretend
like it's not happening now face it but
with clear eyes but why aren't you
panicked well I'm not panicked because
of our financial situation for one thing
right but I'm also not panicked because
I don't see this going on to September
I'm really you know I you know what
gives me a whole lot more stimulus than
the stimulus package for the president
saying we're going back to work but in a
president saying the cure is worse than
the virus hmm it's doing more damage
than the virus and at some point we got
to start balancing these two things
and the and someone finally being
clear-headed and saying we have a real
serious situation with the virus and
we're you know we have to watch that
stuff but being real serious about
saying the economic damage because we
have basically destroyed the hospitality
industry cruise lines the airlines the
hotels and the restaurants there they're
just I mean a bunch of them you will
never see again
they're gone and that's not an
understatement and we destroyed them
with how we decided to fight the virus
and right or wrong well you can make an
argument I'm not I'm not gonna don't you
have to make that argument right I'm
just making a factual statement and if
you continue this in this economy now
you are gonna have a problem you're
gonna have a problem because it's going
to extend past those industries into
everything else and people's livelihoods
how they feed their children how their
futures are based and well you're
putting people's lives at risk now you
know we've made an argument about that
and what is the trade-off will you
really willing to kill granny for the
almighty dollar not willing to kill
anybody's granny for an almighty dollar
that's not the point the point is are
you willing to completely destroy this
economy as your reaction for this virus
and when the president says no we're
going back to work and our governor says
we're going back to work in about
another ten days here in Tennessee then
I think that's a big deal because it's
it's you know it these people's jobs do
matter yeah if everyone in America
starts to become unemployed now you've
got real problems if you give but I just
don't think that's gonna happen
I don't need to really don't see that I
think people have had enough they're
tired of being afraid they're tired of
cowering in their homes they're tired of
the economic impact of the cure now
superseding the the actual disease we
were trying to kill and people are sick
of it I and you know I know some of you
are mad and some of yours too you know
we got hate mail yesterday cuz I Anthony
I were sitting this close
and I'm like well Anthony's been tested
so I'll give him a hug but you know I
mean it's just people are so angry
and an off tilt and it's just time for
us to breathe be kind to extend some
grace to people to disagree with you you
may disagree with me extend me some
grace I'll try to extend some grace to
you if you're wrong it's okay well and
Dave you're right though when people get
fearful and when cable Heming inning
they can get mean and they can get nasty
and I think that's a good reminder for
me as well as although your listeners
out there just to remind yourself to
just meet whatever you meet with grace
to be able to give people some level of
understanding even beyond maybe what
they're do but just to take that level
of Road it's a higher road for you to
take I have a good friend who's
terrified of the virus right now he's
healthy he's not in a risk group it's
all between his ears he's afraid he's
gonna get the flu essentially and he's
terrified of that and he's terrified of
appearing to be socially irresponsible
and he is held up in his house and he's
a good guy he and I are just looking at
this thing completely different and I'm
not a bad guy cuz I'm sitting there
doing the show with you right you know
but he is completely debilitated by his
fear over this and he's really angry
with me because I'm continuing to work
and I'm continuing to travel and I'm
continuing to try to do things to keep
these thousand families that work on our
team fed and he's really angry with me
being socially irresponsible and I'm
doing this under than that and
understand just not to be angry no but
he's he's terrified he's not just
fearful I mean he is holed up in his
home and people are sliding stuff under
the door to him I mean he's not no human
contact and no logical reason for it Wow
other than he's just been watching the
newsreels yeah way too much and I'm
gonna tell you something you get to that
level it's gonna take some work to come
out of that yeah yeah that's a
psychological yeah that's a battle at
this point that's I thought about that
history car is PTSD from this is going
to be massive you know I thought about
that I'll have to pray for him in that
way I'm just kind of pitiful gotta watch
people be mean than our
normally me their relatives and they're
mean to people in Walgreens and it's
just it's not a hand you guys need to be
kind it's funny you say that I went to
go went to the store picked up something
and I told the gentleman I said thank
you
sir and he looked at me and he goes
that's the nicest thing anyone's said to
me all day yeah he said everyone else
has been mean and nasty and I said I'm
sorry sir I said I hope you have a good
day but for him to take the time to
mention Wow yeah it had to be bad fish
be nice see nice people